welcome back to the rock stars I'm Erik
vos and Marvel's upcoming the Eternals
film recently rescheduled to February
2021 and rumor has it has a fully cut
trailer ready to release whatever we
know when we're going to go see movies
again
looks like the MCU installment that will
answer many of our questions like why do
most of the cosmic of into the MCU tend
to revolve around earth what are the
Celestials and what's the deal with
their random sightings throughout the
MCU thus far where are the goddamn
mutants and does kumail's insane ads
mean he's one of them recently longtime
comics writer and Thanos creator jim
Starlin revealed some potentially huge
news about the Eternals that a young a
Thanos may appear in this film I'm gonna
break down everything we know about the
Eternals and spoiler warning in case it
ruins your life okay so some background
the Eternals are immortal beings living
in secret on earth since ancient times
many of them inspiring real-world
mythology's the cast will include Jemma
Chan as Cersei Richard Madden Robb Stark
as Icarus Angelina Jolie as thena camión
on Gianni as Kingo Salma Hayek as a jack
Bryan Tyree Henry as Fastow's Lauren
Britt La Paz Macari Lia McHugh is sprite
Don Lee is Gilgamesh and Barry Killian
as drink Jon Snow
Kit Harington as flame Dean Whitman a
human who falls in love with Cersei most
likely after blowing this eternal secret
wide open in the Marvel Comics the
Eternals were created as an experiment
by the Celestials essentially the gods
of the Marvel Universe
they're big and they wear armor there
have been three Celestials established
so far in the MCU Isan the searcher
shown in the collector's infinity stone
origin story who once wielded the Power
Stone ego Peter Quill's father
identified himself as a celestial in
volume 2 which is a change from ego the
Living Planet in the comics and nowhere
is set in the severed head of another
unknown celestial when the Marvel Comics
was decapitated by the symbiote Clint
our deity know also in Thor Ragnarok one
of the attendees of the Sekar arena was
dressed up as the celestial dope again
real Celestials are thousands of feet
tall the Eternals movie will show us
more Celestials
with concept art showing an additional
four of them in total there are 20 named
Celestials in the Marvel Comics and you
can see all their names there I'm not
gonna bother reading them I really went
through all the Eternals in ancient
times the Celestials created the
Eternals but they also created their
enemies the deviance in this creation
process also yield
both humankind on earth and mutant kind
Thanos is technically an eternal he was
born to eternal ours and Suisan on Titan
but he was born with a deviant gene
making him a free so they nearly stabbed
a baby to death the cinematic universe
appears to be keeping this lineage
intact with red skull identifying Thanos
with his father's name jim Starlin
created the character of Thanos he
actually cameoed in cap support group
and Avengers end game recently comic
books Tom asked Starlin about Thanos's
arc in the films he responded I
understand the story's not completely
ended I think a young Thanos appears in
the Eternals I remember reading that
somewhere they made a shitload of money
off this guy so I don't see them
retiring them anytime soon comic book
characters tend to have an extended
lifespan beyond the actors who work on
them I'm half expecting to see much more
Thanos down the line I love this guy now
Starlin isn't working directly on the
Eternals production but anytime they use
Thanos at a movie since he created the
character he is credited and consulted
in starland statement seems completely
plausible every new Marvel movie
especially for characters that haven't
appeared in movies so far tend to
feature some recognizable tie-ins that
fans already know from past films like
ant-man featured Falcon and the Avengers
upstate campus
Captain Marvel featured adh Nick Fury
and Agent Coulson and the tesseract and
the origins of the Avengers initiative
Doctor Strange was at least teased and
shout out in Winter Soldier and yeah
brought in another infinity stone to the
MCU nothing is truly standalone the
interconnectivity is key in all of these
in the Eternals until now seem to be
just baiting us nerds mostly with the
Celestials concert dirt Celestials being
a background component of the Marvel
mythology that general film goers
probably don't know that much about so
whenever this Eternals trailer comes out
it's got to do something to make
everyone feel like this is definitely a
Marvel film and a subplot focusing on
young Thanos's origin story sounds like
a great way to get the fans excited not
just for that younger bud look at how
come now you know that's the pose it's
hard to know with certainty any of this
stuff just like it's hard to know if
someone has a walnut in their front
pocket if it's so sleek and discreet
sleek and discreet like the ridge in my
hand thanks to the rich for sponsoring
this episode the ridge helps you carry
what you need every
day from their flagship Ridge while it's
their portable charging commuter
backpack they want to make the most out
of what you were bringing with you the
ridge wallet is made of military-grade
materials like titanium and carbon fiber
is a clean stylish design and his
chainsaw proof yes someone tried to
fight this wallet with a freaking
chainsaw and hey you lost this baby is
there forged carbon wallets they do have
other colors including some very
flashing tiki designs this is light and
strong it blends in with your eternally
black shirts like a diamond in the rough
rich makes it easy for you to buy with
free shipping and free returns and a
lifetime guarantee
it's got 30,000 five-star reviews so
yeah they're doing something right they
also have great backpacks and travel
bags with RFID blocking pockets and
optional device charging batteries get
10% off today with free worldwide
shipping and returns by going to rigid
comm slash new rock stars that's Ridge
comm slash new rock stars and use the
code new rock stars find the link of the
video's description look folks think
about it's awfully coincidental for
multiple Infinity stones scattered
across the cosmos after the Big Bang to
end up on earth Odin hit the space stone
in Norway in the 10th century never
explained why the mystic warriors kept
the time stone and Kemara Tosh on earth
when we know from characters like Kruger
that sorcerers exist everywhere but it
has been suggested that the Celestials
had some role in the stones history with
ease on wielding the Power Stone and
nebula describing the soul stones home
of war mirror as the Dominion of death
at the very center of celestial
existence so a young fan owes origin
story and the Eternals could explain
this history it was the Celestials
decision to create the Eternals and the
deviants and humans on earth perhaps the
Celestials goal was to create a
relatively peaceful planet away from the
rest of the conflict with comparatively
primitive technology and they interested
a couple 1finity stones to the Eternals
to help them watch over the planet and
over the millennia maybe the Eternals
kept the planet removed from the war
plagued fates of other planets like if
Thor the dark world dr. Selvig talked
about ancient ruins around the world
that gave the coordinates of the deadly
convergence as a way to help future
societies that could've been one way the
Eternals kept us safe and isolated but
then the discovery of the tesseract by
Red Skull changed everything
launching Hydra launching the Avengers
initiative resulting in this escalation
that Thor pointed out in the first
Avengers
your work with the tesseract is what
drew Loki to it and his allies
it is a signal to all the realms of the
earth is ready for a higher form of war
perhaps the reason this discovery was
made is because the Eternals dropped the
ball distracted by their hidden war with
the deviants
so the Celestials attempt to intervene
and try to end this conflict might have
been Thanos and eternal born
mysteriously with a random deviant gene
a genetic defect that could have been a
hopeful miracle by the Celestials to
bring this Eternals and deviants war to
an end a champion son of both sides and
Thanos to its credit did aim to bring
peace to the universe unfortunately
concluded the only way to do that was a
50% universe wide genocide and based on
his desire to tear apart the universe
and start over an endgame there's
definitely a desire to play celestial in
this guy's mind so yeah there's
certainly an interesting backstory to
how Thanos arrived at this conclusion
the fall of Titan eluded to infinity war
that would be very interesting to see as
a flashback to contextualize the history
of the Eternals and the deviants the
Celestials and the Infinity stones the
VFX artists son infinity war an endgame
already did a pretty damn good job
mapping Josh Brolin's face on Thanos be
that much more of an effort to bring
young Vanus to life using Brolin's boy
face from The Goonies or yeah I guess
they could recast the role with the
younger actor but I'm curious to know if
this fan of sea turtles rumor is true
who do you want to see cast as young
Thanos comment down below with your
thoughts and a big thanks to Tony and
Skippy incipient yeah I don't know on
discord for helping with finding that
Avengers clip the rest of you can join
our exclusive discord when you come into
patreon at patreon.com slash new rock
stars follow me on instagram and twitter
at EA vas following rockstars and
subscribe for breakdowns of everything
marble thanks for watching bye
[Music]